Dre MARIE-CLAIRE BABY
médecin de famille
- Et depuis au moins six mois,
l'achalandage a augmenté
à l'urgence.
- Avec un taux d'occupation
de 130 %, l'urgence de
l'Hôtel-Dieu de Lévis est
la plus achalandée de
la grande région de QUébec.
- Les gens ne savent plus
vers quoi se tourner,
ils se présentent à l'urgence.
- Le ministre de la santé,
Christian Dubé, annonçait
cette semaine la mise en place
d'une cellule de crise.
Elle réunit des PDG de CISSS
et de CIUSSS et des experts
responsables de calmer le jeu
dans les urgences de Montréal.
Mais en région aussi,
les professionnels débordés
auraient aimé en fe.
- La situation n'est pas rose
non plus à Québec puis dans
Chaudière-Appalaches.
AUDREY LABBÉ, v.ntérim
Syndicat prof. en soins Ch-App.
- On a besoin d'une cellule
de crise, nous aussi,
en Chaudière-Appalaches.
On ne comprend pas pourquoi poui
on n'est pas impliqué dans
une cellule de crise.
JOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole
du Parti québécois en santé
- La sitle est
dramatique partout; il faut
avoir une vision d'ensemble
du réseau.
- Pour l'opposition,
inclure les hôpitaux régionaux
dans la cellule de crise
ne serait pas suffisant.
- On ne va pas régler
le problème en mettant ensemble
autour dautour dautour dautour s
administrateurs pour régler
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre,
alors que les gens du terrain
le disent, depuis des moiset det
des solutions à proposer.
VINCENT MARISSAL, député,
Québec solidaire Rosemont
- Si les gens de Québec et
le milieu de Québec réclamen
d'être partie à cette cellule
de crise, soit. Mais encore
une fois, cette cellule de crise
ne fera pas de miracle.
- Ça ne prend pas juste
ule de crise, ça prend
d'autres solutions aussi.
Je crois que c'est un tout.
- Parmi les solutions proposées
par les travailleurset l'opposis
supplémentaire obligatoire,
l'amélioration des services
de premières ligne
et un meilleur recrutement
pour les postes en santé.
- Ça fait 21 ans que je suis
médecin à l'urgence, puis ça
fait 21 ans qu'il y a de la
congestion dans les urgences.
Le plus gros problème du système
de santé, c'est que lesgouverner
être réélus dans quatre ans.
- Par courriel, le cabinet du
ministre de la Santé, Chrisitan
Dubé, indique que c'est parce
que la situation est la plus
critique dans le Grand Montréal,
qu'il se concentre à cet
endroit. Toutefois, les
solutions choisies pour
la métropole pourront ensuite
être appliquées à toutes
les régions.
Ici Flavie Suavcagea,
Radio-Canada, Qué